nobody's got it sorted nobody's got it
worked out one of my friends who's a
millionaire and spends time with
billionaires told me it's idiots all the
way up you can go as high as you want in
any organization in any political party
in any group in the entire world the
people at the top they don't have an
idea about what they're doing either it
is idiots all the way up
what's happening people welcome back to
the show it is the end of 2022 and I
thought it would be just right for me to
do a Roundup of some of my favorite
lessons and insights that I've learned
from the podcast and the newsletter and
life in general over the last year the
last 12 months has been particularly
insane a year ago I wasn't Living in
America I didn't have a visa to even be
here and the show was a quarter to a
fifth of the size that it is now so the
last 150 episodes and 100 million plays
or whatever it is I've learned some
interesting and cool stuff and I figured
that it would be a nice way for me to
round out my Year's learnings and then
maybe remind you of some stuff that
you've forgotten or perhaps tell you
about some things that you missed so
thank you for all of your support over
the last 12 months I really really do
appreciate it uh it's been the craziest
ride and I can't wait to see what next
year has got in store but let's get into
it first up Rogan's value difficulty
conflation so I did Rogan in August time
and he had this little exchange that I
kind of missed at the time and then I
went back and listened to the episode
and it was so good he said look at the
car he's driving look at the watch he's
wearing look at the girl he's with
that's unattainable to many people so it
seems like it's valuable but then you
attained it and then you realized oh
this is not valuable this is just
difficult to get and there's a
difference there's a big difference
what's valuable is something that
fulfills you intellectually emotionally
spiritually and lovingly so what I
learned from this was most smart people
realize that there is value in stepping
outside of their comfort zone and doing
something that's difficult we're told
that worthwhile things are difficult to
attain because if they weren't difficult
to attain they probably wouldn't be
worthwhile because everybody could
attain them but this is how non-valuable
but difficult things get slipped into
our desires without us noticing so
attaining something worthwhile is often
going to be difficult but just because
it's difficult doesn't mean that it's
worthwhile so we use the difficulty or
the challenge of attaining something as
a proxy for the value that it has it
just helped me remember that taking your
desires from other people that sort of
mimetic thing where you see somebody
else who has gone through an awful lot
to try and achieve a particular goal you
think wow that's something that's super
worthwhile it's like well what if you
don't care about having a big house or a
flash Rolex or a new car what if you
don't care about the net worth of the
people who you're friends with or about
whether you've got the most followers on
Instagram just because it's hard for
somebody to achieve that thing does not
mean that it is worthwhile and it's that
confusion of the two that really made a
lot of sense and this was Rogan
responding to
kind of my
early years I suppose through my
twenties where I'd done something that
everybody else presumed I I thought was
going to be worthwhile because everybody
else held it in high esteem so yeah that
was um that was a really interesting
little insight from him and then I came
up with the name so uh Rogan's value
difficulty conflation there will be a
lot of bro signs today that is like a
warning there should be a little bro
science alarm counter up there all right
next one Jordan Peterson so this is uh
from the first episode that I did with
him nearly two years ago now so this is
start of 2021 uh and I totally missed it
when he said it and someone reposted a
clip and it just reminded me how good
this little section is so contemplate
the price you pay for an action you're
already in a little hell you know
perfectly well it's going to get worse
the thing about inaction is they are
blind to it do not make the assumption
that inaction has no price so this is
really really interesting like if you're
stuck with a difficult decision it can
be very easy to push it off right so a
change of job or an awkward conversation
or finally approaching somebody that you
fancy or something like that in these
situations it's easy to assume that
doing nothing is the same as an
impartial strategy right if you do not
do a thing you're not moving the
situation forward and or back but doing
nothing is still doing something and
gwynda Bogle says a problem postponed is
a problem extended so this anxiety cost
thing which I spoke to Peterson about
continues to stack up as you spend more
and more hours thinking about the undone
task or objective or whatever it is that
you still haven't gone to go and do as
you thought Loop your way through
not moving forward in the real world and
just vacillating about it inside of your
own mind you end up
in purgatory right it's this liminal
space and nothing is actually being
gained here so sometimes you need to
carefully consider
more options and get more information
but Alex homozy said on the episode I
did with him it doesn't take time to
make decisions it takes information to
make decisions if you have the
information to make the decision you
should make it a lot of people belabor a
decision because they're not gaining
more information to make it time is not
a requirement for decision making
information is if you have the
information to support that this is a
good or bad decision and you still have
fear then this is the fear of the
unknown or hypothetical which is not
knowable we don't know what is going to
happen but we have evidence that would
support this decision that makes sense
if we still don't want to make it then
that is not logical so you have to
contemplate the price that you pay for
in action and a lot of the time what
you're waiting for is not actually
contributing to you being able to make
the decision any more easily if
postponing a problem extends it and if
there is a price that you pay for an
action and if time doesn't help you make
decisions information does and you are
not getting more information as you wait
all that you're doing is postponing that
problem and you are not not making a
decision you are continuing to push that
out so you know any large decision any
difficult decision that you feel like
I don't know you just you're not sure
whether or not you're going to pull the
pin on this thing so you sit back and
you wait you wait and you wait and time
just continues to pass and you presume
that this is a an impartial independent
strategy that's not the case that's not
the way that this works unfortunately
and um it's a nice reminder of the
urgency of
um
doing anything I think you know
Parkinson's law of work expands to fill
the time given for it if you are if you
have no deadline for the decision that
you're going to make you're just going
to continue pushing it off and off and
off and reminding yourself that there is
a price that you pay for inaction is a
nice way to kind of add a little bit of
urgency into everything you do
next up Roy Baumeister so Roy was like
pretty base it was like Roy based
Meister
um when he came on I was very very
impressed with him and he wrote this
great book about
sex like sociosexuality he came on and
we had a great conversation about it he
has this like really really interesting
take about uh the relationship between
women's demands of men and what men will
do in order to get laid so he said uh
men will do what women demand of them in
order to get laid women set the
standards for sex and Men meet them
although this may be considered an
unflattering characterization we have
found no evidence to contradict the
basic General principle that men will do
whatever is required in order to obtain
sex and perhaps not a great deal more
one of us characterized this in a
previous work as if women would stop
sleeping with jerks men would stop being
jerks if in order to obtain sex men must
become pillars of the community or lie
or amass riches by fair means or foul or
be romantic or funny then many men will
do precisely that if men need to simply
be in the right place at the right time
at 3am in a nightclub then they will
meet these standards appropriately women
are not at fault for listlessness in men
but they're not totally unrelated to it
either
this went down quite badly on Instagram
as you might be able to imagine but I
think that there's a lot of Truth in
this it is not men who set these
standards and criteria that they have to
meet for sex right women are The
Gatekeepers to sex fundamentally in men
are the protagonists sometimes this is
reversed I'm not sure if it's quite
still the same situation where uh women
are The Gatekeepers to sex and Men Are
The Gatekeepers to relationships I think
that that Dynamic is moving at least a
little bit but for the most part like
it's the woman that says yes or no about
who she is or is not going to go to bed
with and having a situation where
um
lower
uh a lower price that is being demanded
of men uh in order for them to achieve
sex you know take it back 200 years the
year that Darwin was born I think it's
like 1830 or something like that the
average number of people registering for
divorce in the UK was four per year
that's not 100 that's not a thousand
that's four four people per year we're
registering for divorce in the UK in the
mid-1800s
that means that the price that you need
to pay in order to get divorced is
significantly higher
divorce was much rarer also if the price
that you need to pay in order to be able
to get access to sex is that you need to
court a woman for a good while and speak
to her father like think about why it is
that the asking the father for the
daughter's hand in marriage thing was
even there I guess that there'll be some
like interesting cultural reason for it
but also you could think about it from a
just social psychology perspective
it is presumably one of the most
difficult disagreeable people in This
Woman's entire life and the guy is going
to him
as a final hurdle that they've got to
get over it's like look
do you consider me to be so little or an
appropriate appropriately low level of a
piece of [ __ ] so that I can marry your
daughter given the fact that
divorce is going to be relatively rare
many hundred years ago
why is that there well it's there to be
the final quality control check because
it's a big deal and if there was no sex
outside of marriage yes there was there
was like brothels and whatnot but for
the most part it would have been
significantly less common for people to
have sex outside of marriage men will do
all of the different things that they
need to because they want to get laid
now if the price that they're being
asked is dropping and dropping and
dropping now you don't have to ask for
the father's hand in marriage now you
don't need to be married at all now you
don't need to have a good job now you
don't need to have a good standing in
the community now you just need to be in
the right place at the right time
that is the standard that men will meet
for sex again the listlessness that you
see amongst men is like very
multifactorial right it's coming from
all manner of different places both
self-generated by men it's contributed
to by culture but I don't think that you
can say that women don't contribute to
this at all I think that that would be
like a
it is them that set the price for sex
right and men are meeting or not meeting
it uh appropriately
all right next one Ryan holiday I know
he's very unpopular among certain
circles but I fundamentally disagree
with the Viewpoint that because you
disagree with someone on one perspective
that they've taken that you should throw
out everything else that they say and
he's got his book discipline is Destiny
from this year I thought was fantastic
and this quote really really nailed it
for me so talking about the thing and
doing the thing VI for the same
resources allocate your energy
appropriately talking about the thing
and doing the thing via for the same
resources allocate your energy
appropriately so there actually is I
think human speaks about this the same
system that gives you
um reward mechanisms and makes you feel
good for completing a task can actually
be
um manipulated it can be triggered by
simply talking about the task as well so
you are have been dreaming for a very
long time that you want to finally start
a business and make it out on your own
so you begin to speak to your friends
about it and you kind of get this sense
of satisfaction and progression when you
speak to your friends about the business
that you're going to start
and that actually encourages you to not
start the business because the sense of
satisfaction that you get can
um push off the requirement for you to
make action in order to feel
satisfaction now that being said there
is a another element here that if you
start to talk to people about something
you're going to do they're going to
begin to push you and there is a sense
of identity continuation that you need
to do right so someone you tell someone
I'm going to start a business pretty
soon and then they say I thought you
were starting that business whatever you
got up to with that you go oh [ __ ] like
I actually need to start doing something
because there is external pressure so
there is sort of a couple of different
elements going on in this Dynamic but
for sure if you find yourself not making
progress in a particular area of your
life and you have got external
accountability it would be a really good
idea to look at am I talking about this
an awful lot am I giving myself a great
sense of satisfaction from discussing
this my housemate Zach is exactly the
same he actually holds back on talking
about stuff
because he is concerned that it is going
to down regulate his motivation to go
and do it it's not a bad solution for
that I don't know
um I really really enjoyed that that
quote though talking about the thing and
doing the thing Vie for the same
resources allocate your energy
appropriately it also encourages you to
just focus on executing right it's like
look I need to focus on doing the thing
talking about the thing is never going
to be as important as doing the thing
ever and it is so much easier to
strategize than is to execute does that
um stat I think it's from LinkedIn that
says strategy and strategizing are in
the 10 most common bio words in all of
LinkedIn and execute or executor aren't
in the top 1000 so a kind of funny
example but it's obvious that people
focus on strategizing because it's
easier than executing and it's seductive
and it triggers all of those dopamine
Pathways as well all right next one
it's not about brainwashing or
indoctrination the goal of propaganda is
to control what you think other people
think this is a Rob Henderson one
it's not about brainwashing or
indoctrination the goal of propaganda is
to control what you think other people
think now that's really interesting
because
what we're doing when it comes to
forging our own opinions a lot of the
time is
observing what other people around us
think and we don't really want to go
against them all that much especially if
it's people that we
um resonate with or we admire or we
identify with and the way that news now
is distributed is that there is a news
channel for each different cohort of
people so you know the New York Times is
for this group and the New York Post is
for that group and the guardian and BBC
and so on and so forth each different
news organization has a self-identifying
group of people that follow it and read
what it says so it means that if they
can convince you that all of the other
people who also consume that particular
type of media think the thing that they
are telling you about you are
significantly more likely to believe in
it and that's dangerous because you can
observe a an article on its own merits
right and be critical and skeptical
cynical appropriately of that one piece
of content
but when it then turns to you trying to
ignore the influence of other people and
whether they believe in it or not
that's really difficult because we are
inbuilt social creatures who have
influence from others we don't want to
be on the outside if you lived in a
hundred person tribe you don't want to
be one out of 100 that doesn't agree
with whatever Vision the leader has
right and I still think that there's
some mapping that goes on where we see
the
um
thought leaders of the world the media
organizations of the world as that a
proxy for that leader they still take up
that role even if they rightly shouldn't
and even if we're able to step in and
have that sort of skepticism and
cynicism ourselves
when it gets distributed out and it's
like no no like you don't need to listen
to us everybody thinks this that's
dangerous and Rob also had this other
great thing that I learned I learned
from him called the hendersonian news
cycle I I came up with the with the name
so don't blame him for it
um all news stories follow the same
process so step one it's not really
happening so uh inflation isn't
happening and likely won't here are
seven charts showing this uh step two
yeah it's happening but it isn't a big
deal
for instance at times like these
inflation isn't all bad step three it's
a good thing actually
for instance why the inflation we're
seeing is now a good thing and step four
people freaking out about it are the
real problem Americans need to learn to
live more like Europeans so each of
these are actual titles tracking the
progression of inflation and its denial
basically by the mainstream media over
time
and that little cycle that moves from uh
denial into
um
uh down uh like a down tuning of how
important it is into a reversal of
whether it's a good or a bad thing and
then finally into blame of the people
who are identifying that it's a problem
I mean you can map that Henderson news
cycle onto absolutely everything so yeah
keep your eyes out for that all right
next one uh gwynda's theory of bespoke
[ __ ] many people don't have an
opinion until they ask for it at which
point they Cobble together a Viewpoint
from whim and half remembered hearsay
before deciding that this two minute old
makeshift opinion will be their new Hill
to die on
[ __ ] brilliant so good and makes a
lot of sense around why
seemingly unsophisticated viewpoints by
people that you're kind of uh skeptical
or critical about uh the depth of
thought that they've put into it
why they're so passionate about that
particular Viewpoint you go well hang on
a second like if if you're a
um introspective person who is generally
trying to
rationally assess their views on a
regular basis you will often speak with
like caveats right you will try and talk
in a way that is uh it Hedges it doesn't
speak in absolutes because maybe you
don't know and then when you see
somebody out in the wild who is
absolutely 100 passionate and and
certain about whatever it is they're
talking about you go well
they they must have done their research
the only way that I could get myself to
a place where I am that certain about
anything would be if I was completely
bulletproof I've done all of the
research I know everything front to back
I got all of the examples of the counter
arguments that the opponents would say
about it everything I'm totally boxed
off
that sort of leads to a position where
it it becomes easy for us to believe
that other people's views are more
sophisticated than they are or that
they've done the work and the rigor the
requisite rigor in order to have that
level of certainty around whatever it is
that they're saying uh and it can it can
really give people a sense of it can
give others a degree of reputability of
their particular Viewpoint right it it
makes us believe that this person has
done all of the requisite research in
order to arrive at a place where they
are that certain about something they
know the other side's arguments they
know that they they've done every single
bit of research front to back left to
right they know all of this stuff inside
out and this comes to something I've
Loved for a long time which is strong
opinions loosely held not loose opinion
strongly held if you don't really know
what you're talking about and yet you're
going to die in order to save it that's
a stupid position right that's just
outright [ __ ] it which is what
gwynda's highlighting here so yeah
strong opinions loosely held you should
be open to changing your mind almost at
all times there's this other great quote
that I'm going to butcher which was
um
if you can't State what information
would cause you to change your mind
about a particular topic then you do not
have a a rational view you have a
religious ideology belief right if if
there is no evidence that could convince
you otherwise of whatever your
particular stance on one thing is that
that's no longer that that is literally
like you bowing down to some sacred text
you need to be open to having your mind
Changed by things that's the strong
opinions Lucy held not loose opinions
strongly held Okay so
next up was an Insight around uh dealing
with critics and others judgment so
um this year I suppose it's been kind of
unique for me those things every year
has been over the since the beginning of
the show were
the amount of exposure
has been
I don't know like 20 times more like 30
30 or 40 times more than it was in
previous years
and I found myself becoming
um like more
ambiently aware and and slightly anxious
of just all of the eyeballs that are on
you and no one really
no never really seems to complain or or
bring that up as a price that you pay
because you go look like you're putting
content out there and you're it's you
that chooses to be the person saying
these things like how can you start to
complain about them people watching you
and you feeling like this
ambient eyeball on you this huge ambient
eyeball like it's it's just the price
that you pay and you knew that that was
the case that's true but it didn't stop
me from feeling uh some sense of like
surveillance that was kind of going on
uh so a good bit of what I've been
trying to learn about this year is
dealing with that sense of other
people's judgment and criticism and
whatnot and um
this quote came up which was brilliant
and it said uh stop worrying so much
about other people liking you most
people don't even like themselves and
that was important for me as I've tried
to sort of deprogram this
self-consciousness over the last few
years because I always thought and I
think this is part of being an only
child that other humans had some sort of
brilliantly balanced existence and that
any opinion of me was created through
this perfectly accurate and fair
assessment and that they were normal
and correct and I was in relation
somehow deficient right and the problem
is that we only ever see a tiny little
sliver of other people's motivations and
thought processes right we only ever get
to see what they choose to say and then
what we see them say and then that's
compressed down into whatever the tiny
bit rate of what they send over the
internet on a Twitter tweet or what they
speak out of their mouth but we observe
our own vacillations and uncertainty and
foibles and self-doubt from a front row
seat it's it's ten thousand times a
second we observe our own brain go
through the odd machinations as it
tumbles backward and forward between
whatever failure is it it is that that
we haven't the self-doubt and whatnot
really comes through with that whereas
most people don't show that most other
people just seem like normal well put
together human beings and it makes
everybody else look
slick and rational while we look like
wavering idiots and it's been my belief
especially as I've started to spend more
time around people that are unbelievably
competent and have stories around people
that are even more competent
most people most of the time don't have
any idea what they're doing like
adulthood is like being pushed down a
set of steps at the age of 18 and just
trying to control yourself and stop
yourself from falling all the way until
you die like nobody's got it sorted
nobody's got it worked out one of my
friends who's a millionaire and spends
time with billionaires told me it's
idiots all the way up you can go as high
as you want in any organization in any
political party in any group in the
entire world the people at the top they
don't have an idea about what they're
doing either it is idiots all the way up
and I think
remembering that the self-doubt that you
feel in yourself and the
um
promises that you make the deals that
I'm going to get up at whatever time I'm
gonna get up at
7am tomorrow morning and then you hit
snooze three times and you go oh my God
this proves that I'm the piece of [ __ ]
that I've always thought I was like
other people are doing that as well the
only difference is that you don't get to
see it and that was
um
the fallibility I think of people who
are unbelievably competent is something
that's like really really important to
see it's one of the reasons I'm trying
as best I can to be open and honest when
I fall flat on my face on the show
because
um if other people can see this
progression over time of someone who
seems to be you know doing well in their
chosen Pursuit the show is growing and I
are becoming more competent at it and
you know growth and money and plays and
all that stuff but if I'm still kind of
waving the flag for like I'm a [ __ ]
idiot like I make mistakes on a secondly
basis I break promises to myself
that should hopefully humanize
any idea of
um progress and progression and and
achievement and attainment and
um
anything along that path as being way
less mystical and sort of perfect than
it actually is like it's not it's it's
idiots all the way up there's this other
quote that said we would care far less
about what other people thought of us if
we realized how rarely they did because
not only do most people not have any
idea what they're doing they're also so
wrapped up in their own existence that
they have no time to consider us and one
of my friends at the party said when was
the last time that you remember somebody
spilling their drink or knocking some
food down themselves like I I literally
can't remember and yet if you did it to
yourself you go oh my God you know this
just proves that I'm the the clumsy
idiot everybody's thinking about it I'm
never gonna get to live this down but
the fact that there's this asymmetry
that you can't remember it and yet think
that everybody else will be able to if
you're the one that does it is the most
liberating thing that you can think and
remember I think about social life like
almost no one cares about you and almost
no one will remember you after you leave
the room so there's no point in being
self-conscious and then the final quote
that brought all of this together from
Rick and Morty which is Rick Sanchez
your booze mean nothing I've seen what
makes you cheer most people live in
default unassessed lives completely at
the mercy of their programming following
whatever desires Society told them to
like if you could see the inner texture
of the people who don't like use
existence I think you'd probably feel
more pity than anger basically most
critics are miserable idiots and you're
doing fine
that's it
there's also actually another quote that
someone just some random person on
Twitter sent the other day that said
people with low self-esteem will always
find a way to be miserable
I thought that was kind of interesting
because
there is a um
a particular predisposition or like a a
rhythm a Tanner a tone that is
um consistently put out by certain
individuals online and you go what is it
why what's about that particular
person's world view that is causing them
to behave in that way and if you look
for instance there are the people
that'll comment on the YouTube or
whatever and if you press on the person
I don't know whether you can do this as
a view you might actually be able to do
this yourself but I can certainly do it
on the back end if I press on the
person's profile let's say that they put
a
I know like kind of an unhinged or like
an angry or seemingly uh unrelated or
disproportionate
um response you can press on them and I
can see everything that they've ever
commented on the channel
so many times it is the exact same tone
and you go well that's personality you
know that's what personality is well
yeah but if it's always miserable is
that is their personality be [ __ ]
miserable like is that really what
they're defined by they're defined by
misery on the internet
I'm not sure but people with low
self-esteem will always find a way to be
miserable is really interesting Insight
because you go well they will reverse
engineer any situation in order to be
able to create reality uh to mold it
into a situation that justifies their
predisposition their predisposition of
being miserable uh yes there are people
that have low self-esteem for a myriad
of other reasons but I do think that
that for the normies out there who
haven't had tons of past trauma like
there are people out there who are
simply just miserable because they don't
want the world to be any different and
they are consistently that way and you
can see it if you click on their
comments on YouTube
all right so then I did uh Jocko halfway
through the year right and
that was wild because I did huberman and
I did Jocko in the space of
six days six a week in a bit right
so we've got human out here in Austin
and I'm learning every different type of
Neuroscience and going through all of
this stuff about biohacking and I'm like
right stop switch let's go to trying to
learn to be a hard bastard seal and um
one of the episodes that I listen to in
preparation for Jocko was this thing he
did with Sam Harris and it was
four five years ago it was when Joker
first burst onto the scene and it was
really really interesting this insight
about bravery he says you can't fake
bravery as an emotion you can fake being
angry or upset or whatever but if you
fake bravery when you're terrified
that's bravery doing the thing in spite
of being terrified is what bravery is
and I think that there's a parallel here
with motivation which was a lot of the
conversation I had with Jocko Jocko is
the discipline kills motivation
discipline eats motivation for breakfast
right so a lot of people over complicate
motivation because they believe that
motivation is some necessary precursor
to doing the thing so this it's an
optimal mental state when you finally
feel ready to do it or like you want to
do it or something but you can't fake
motivation like no matter how motivated
you feel if you don't do the thing you
weren't sufficiently motivated and even
if you don't feel motivated at all and
you do do the thing then that is
motivation so
it's impossible to fake it is completely
impossible to fake motivation
if you judge it by did I get the work
done if you judge it by this super
wishy-washy ethereal State it's like I
really want to just feel empowered and
energized about something like yeah
great that's motivation but if that
doesn't end up getting you the end
result if you moving closer toward the
thing that you're supposed to do
what's the [ __ ] point of it and then
Jocko agreed and he said that's why I
preferred discipline to motivation
motivation is fleeting it comes and goes
discipline is always there you don't
need to want to go to the gym or
meditate or walk your dog or have a
difficult conversation with your partner
you simply need to do the thing and by
doing the thing you shortcut the need
for motivation entirely
go and do the thing and that's why if
you follow me on Twitter I've been
tweeting do the thing or your weekly
reminder to just do the thing
it's a good uh
a good sort of kick in the ass that you
really should focus on
the outcomes you know the motivation all
of the vacillating beforehand all of the
listening to rock music and and taking
heavy amounts of caffeine or whatever it
is that you're doing all of that doesn't
matter unless it actually is in service
if you're going and doing a thing and
over complicating motivation is
something that I think is becoming more
prevalent rather than less
okay so
um started this year uh I go and do that
episode with Peterson out in San Antonio
and it was a a wild trip because I'd
only just got back to Austin went
straight from Austin essentially to San
Antonio like dumped my stuff here went
straight to San Antonio with video guy
Dean uh and then from there flew
straight from San Antonio like from the
episode with Peterson got my bag went
downstairs got into a car went to the
plane flew landed in New York so I'd
started the morning in San Antonio
recorded the podcast and then by 10 p.m
at night was having dinner in New York
and then by 12 p.m at night I was at
Douglas Murray's so I stayed with
Douglas for a couple of days and then I
went off and started recording the show
again in New York and Douglas was uh
making what was it called a Manhattan
I'd never had a Manhattan before if you
haven't had a Manhattan it is a cocktail
which exclusively has alcohol in it
there is no I don't think there's
anything that is a part of the
ingredients list
that isn't alcoholic so it's like two in
the morning for a few nights in a row
and Douglas is just filled with stories
the guy's just I can an endless novel
creator of all of the different things
that he's done so I'm just sat there
like listening to a live rendition of
the best audiobook that I could think of
them start swelling a fourth Manhattan
that I've had as I'm half cut staring at
one eye and
he was telling me the story about
um
Christopher Hitchens and he was saying
that
Douglas was vacillating between two
different options that he had in his
life he didn't really know which one it
was that he wanted to do and and if he
didn't do one of them the opportunity
cost of of missing out was gonna it was
going to kill him and he asked hitch
about this and he apparently was smoking
some cigar and you can imagine him in
like the I don't know the back room of
some British pub or something like that
with a Chesterfield Couch behind him
like poked the leather holes in it and
stuff and he smokes this and he goes
Douglas in life we must choose our
regrets
I was like
holy [ __ ] what does it mean
what's it what's it mean that we have to
choose our regrets and I never really
considered things in that way
I'd never considered I'd always had this
assumption I suppose that
it's somehow possible to get through
life without having regrets if you are
to make the right decisions if you got
everything right you wouldn't have any
regrets if you made precisely the right
decisions at the right moment maybe you
could totally avoid regrets entirely and
I'd presumed that any regret is the side
the byproduct of a sub-optimal decision
and I'd never considered that regrets
could perhaps be unavoidably baked into
the fabric of life so they're not
bugs their features right so upon
reflection it kind of seems easy so if
you think that opportunity cost by doing
a thing you can't do another thing right
it demands that you sacrifice one thing
in order to be able to do another and
you can make the absolute best choice
and still regret not doing the other
thing
plus we don't know what choice was
optimal so even if you have an amazing
time you have the choice between going
to the supermarket or going to the gym
right by going to the supermarket you
can't go to the gym even if you know
that going to the gym is the right
choice you'll always wonder about what
it was like to go to the supermarket and
you don't get to run it again so you
don't actually get to know if it was the
right choice so regrets are unavailable
now is that right okay that's that's
interesting that you regrets are baked
in and you can't get away from them but
what does it mean that you have to
choose your regrets
well a lot of the time you're going to
incur some pain no matter what decision
it is that you make so you need to
choose let's say between a relationship
and a new job new job's going to get you
to go away relationship requires you to
stay at home either decision is going to
cause regret and given the fact that
regrets are unavoidable right because
they're features they're not bugs which
regret do you want like this adds so
much Clarity to Big difficult decisions
because rather than working out which
decision you could live with you get to
imagine which decision you couldn't bear
living without so which regrets could
you put up with having chosen
and which could you never forgive
yourself for that is in life we must
choose our regrets and that blew my head
off and that was he goes to the bathroom
and there's me like half cut with one
eye open typing this thing down quickly
in life choose regrets because I'd be
able to remember the story and I managed
to uh but had I have not written it down
I would have forgotten it uh over the
top of some cosmopolitans
but that's just such an interesting
Insight that you have to choose your
regrets in life
you don't get to go through life without
them and what's that uh Thomas Soul
quote
um in there are no Solutions only
trade-offs right that's the same thing
that's the exact same insight there are
no Solutions only trade-offs you don't
get to have no regrets you simply get to
choose which regrets you want to have
and given that
you should be a regret optimization
machine
how can I get myself to the stage where
all of the regrets that I had were the
ones that I wanted to have they were the
optimal regrets for me like that's what
you want to optimize for
okay Dr Russell Kennedy so this this is
like a little
three-part uh little three-parter to
consider uh the relationship between our
mind and our body and Dr Russell Kennedy
the guy that wrote anxiety RX he is an
MD he's a neuroscientist and he was a
psychiatrist as well this guy was very
credentialed but he had quite a
sort of forward-thinking view when it
came to anxiety and he had this little
quote that said you can't think your way
out of a feeling problem I was like
that's cool like
we do try you feel angry or you feel sad
or you feel whatever and you try and
think your way out of it now even if you
come from the purest mindfulness
vipassana side of the world if you're
going to meditate your way out of it
you're not thinking right you're
actually doing the opposite you're
releasing you're letting go you're
relaxing and you're allowing
and everything's just falling away
you're not thinking your way out of the
feeling problem and then huberman the
first thing that I spoke to him about
when he came on the show was his famous
quote that says you cannot control the
mind with the mind you have to use the
body this isn't strictly true I think
because meditation is the mind helping
the mind to relax itself it's not
strictly the Mind controlling the mind
and I do think that
um applying more cognitive effort to a
cognitive problem
sometimes doesn't really help which is
highlighted perfectly by uh George Mack
my friend from four and a half years ago
on the show who said trying to think
your way out of overthinking is like
trying to sniff your way out of a
cocaine addiction and
those three together you can't think
your way out of a feeling problem you
cannot control the mind with the mind
you have to use the body and trying to
think your way out of overthinking is
like trying to sniff your way out of a
cocaine addiction
you can take them as a whole to
basically see the the body is a single
unit the body and the mind are one
system and trying to separate the two is
is kind of
uh hopeless and increasingly as guys
like huberman and Dr Russell Kennedy as
well release more information about how
intrinsically linked our mood and our
bodies are you do realize like look I
need to I I feel X I feel agitated or
frustrated or sad or whatever it is it's
like okay I could try and sit here and
cognitive like apply cerebral uh
horsepower in an effort to try and push
this away or I could just go for a walk
or I could go cold plunger I could go
sooner or I could train or I could see a
friend or I could have a conversation or
I could journal the bottom line is that
trying to think your way out of thinking
problems doesn't really work and trying
to think your way out of feeling
problems doesn't really work and trying
to rely exclusively on cerebral
horsepower to fix problems that are
occurring in the mind or the body also
doesn't really work so it has to be this
whole kind of holistic
um fully ecological view of both
yourself and your surroundings and the
environment that you're in and your
routines and your habits and so on and
you know if you listen to the show and
you are a obviously an unbelievably
mindful very well-balanced insightful
person because they're the only people
that listen to this podcast
if that is you
I do want to warn you about
the temptation of tumbling into
praying at the altar of sort of cerebral
horsepower too much you know we learned
some [ __ ] amazing stuff on this
podcast like things that I I didn't I
couldn't have even imagined were things
to learn
and it's so fascinating and so
insightful and I can only presume that
it's if it's even one percent is
interesting for you guys as it is for me
then it means that you're going to be
blown away by the power of the human
mind and what you get to see especially
on this podcast is some of the best
Minds in the world's Minds on display
you get to see them just
like cracking the skull open and just
allowing this information to fall out of
them but that doesn't mean that that is
the ultimate that relying exclusively on
cognitive horsepower is the ultimate um
altar that we should pray at it's like
let's try and have a more holistic whole
body View and I think that the guys like
huberman and Dr Russell Kennedy that are
talking about this is a really important
counterbalance to people for whom
overthinking and an over-reliance on
that cognition side uh is maybe their
default or maybe that's their learned uh
Behavior it's just a trend or a phase
that they're going through
um for some people they need to think a
lot more right I know a lot of people
that could do with being a little bit
more sort of introspective and
self-assessing when it comes to what
they do
but for a lot of people it's not for a
lot of people actually need to get
themselves out of their head and one of
the best things I've done this year is
actually starting to play Pickleball of
all things so
I know right I'm like the most Austin
person subsume my entire personality has
been subsumed by Austin because I've got
a cold plunge tub outside and I play
Pickleball and now I've got cracks with
socks on um
but
the advantage that I found and I really
wanted this as a Pursuit I wanted to do
something
that was that would take me out of my
mind and was exclusively for the
enjoyment of the task so I bought this
exercise desk that I've been helping on
about all this year uh and
it's great but the reason that I use it
is because I know that hitting 180
minutes of Zone 2 cardio per week is
beneficial to my heart rate variability
and it improves longevity and here's the
studies and whatever whatever like yeah
sure enough I feel better once I finish
but it's not like
it's not amazing like I don't I don't
love it
so even those exercises and even
bodybuilding you know I get to go and
train with my boys and it's fun and
there's music and we're throwing down
and whatever but it's not
purely for the enjoyment of what I'm
doing right there so I really wanted to
find a Pursuit that would not only take
me out of my mind right so just allowing
that to have a little bit of time to
switch off but not for not doing it in
service of some greater goal like doing
it for the pure enjoyment of it and
imagine if you could dance that that
would be kind of like doing dance or
it'd be like doing yoga or Tai Chi or
any sort of embodiment practice and for
me right now my embodiment practice
would be something like pickleball I'm
assessing what I'm doing with my body
but I'm not thinking about it and it's
not in service of some greater goal it's
not because
Studies have shown that two hours of
pickleball a week for eager increases
gray matter percentage in the brain by
five percent and synapse efficiency or
something like I'm not doing it for that
reason I'm doing it because I enjoy
pickleball so yeah that would be that's
the the takeaway that's how I've applied
a bunch of the stuff that the guys have
put in there all right next one so this
was a quote from why Buddhism is true by
Robert Wright which I read probably
three or four years ago and then this
appeared on my read-wise read wise is
this sort of uh
um
app that resurfaces highlights from
Kindle it's pretty cool if you if you
haven't used it before and it says
ultimately happiness comes down to
choosing between the mental discomfort
of becoming aware of your afflictions or
the discomfort of becoming ruled by them
so
this was the fundamental Insight I
gained and why I've become so interested
in evolutionary psychology this year
which is
we are at the mercy of our programming
for the most part as Jonathan height
calls it we are a writer atop an
elephant right and although we think
that we're in control for the most part
the elephant is moving us forward and
we're kind of you know puppets on the
end of strings or Riders atop of
elephants that we don't really get that
much control over what's going on but
for every amount for every percent that
you begin to get more aware of what your
predispositions are why they are that
way why is it that you have a preference
for this particular type of partner or
for this particular type of food or for
this particular type of activity why are
you reverse to these different things
why is it so hard to get up early in the
morning why is it so hard for women to
go to the gym and train when they're in
the second half of their ovulatory cycle
like you know each of the different
things each of the different episodes
that's happened this year to me is one
more insight into becoming aware of our
mental afflictions and
you can quite easily go through life
without viewing that right I I don't
appear into my own programming I don't
want to understand how it is that I
operate but you are by definition
putting yourself at the mercy of that
being your ruler right there is no way
that you can rule anything that you're
not aware of it's just not going to
happen and given the fact that we are so
driven by our programming becoming aware
of it has to be the first step on route
to becoming
uh less at the mercy of it so I really
love that ultimately happiness comes
down to choosing between the discomfort
of becoming aware of your mental
afflictions or the discomfort of
becoming ruled by them and a similar one
from Greg McEwen which is kind of
applied to life design that again read
wise resurfaced this year which is great
uh you have to focus on progress toward
a specific thing in the medium term or
sacrifice meaningful progress toward
everything in the long term you have to
focus on progress towards a specific
thing in the medium term or sacrifice
meaningful progress toward everything in
the long term I said this on Rogan as
well where you can be anything you want
but you can't be everything you want in
the modern world given that we have so
many options on
ubereats deliveroo Amazon whatever app
you want wherever it is that you want to
go to to fly whatever you want to learn
about and read
it creates a blue sky Vision which is
very good for creativity but is
sub-optimal when it comes to you
thinking about how am I going to design
my life
yes you can learn about anything you
want to on the internet but you don't
have an infinite amount of years that
you can spend applying that to your life
and if you try to learn absolutely
everything the Jack of all trades master
of none comes through like and it'll
kill you
you need to focus on something in the
short term or in the medium term as well
if you don't you're constantly going to
be cycling your wheels you're constantly
going to be distracted by that new shiny
thing and Oliver Berkman from 4000 weeks
had another great Insight that you could
put in this as well which is if you're
going to have a committed period of
focused work on a small number of
projects which you should always be
doing
if you're going to do that you need to
decide in advance what you're going to
suck at because inevitably when you do
decide to focus on some things that
means that you can't focus on other
things so this is the opportunity cost
opportunity anxiety open loop stuff that
Douglas Murray learned from Christopher
Hitchens from earlier on
if that's going to happen inevitably
some things are going to start to slip
away so let's say that next year in 2023
you really want to focus on uh your
business right so I'm gonna make as much
money as possible I'm going to grow the
business as much as possible or I'm
going to get as far along in my career
as I can or I'm going to get a new job
that's my thing if I got to the end of
2023 and I was in a new job or a new
career or I was earning more money I had
the business had grown or whatever that
would be a success to me
you have to concede that your physique
and maybe your relationships are going
to take a hit
if you genuinely care about the fact
that you're going to make progress
toward your business goals over the next
year if in 2023 you want to grow your
business you have to concede the fact
that your body is going to get worse and
if and when it does you need to be
prepared for that and that's why it's so
important to decide in advance what
you're going to suck at because when
that does happen a lot of the time if
you're a growth-minded person that's a
type a go-getter like you probably are
you're going to feel
um pain because you go [ __ ] I'm I'm
supposed to be able to get everything
like competent people aren't supposed to
let things slip away from them I I I'll
start going to the gym a little bit more
because I don't want to feel out of
shape but you decided in advance that
this was the thing that you're going to
suck at like look I understand that
because there is a limited amount of
time that I can spend and I have a
limited amount of bandwidth and effort
that I can put into 2023 in order to be
successful at one thing I need to
sacrifice some other things and when
those sacrifices come up and things
start to slip away that's fine like that
is
by Design what's supposed to happen you
could even see it as an indication that
yes I am focusing on other things is it
going to be great if you get to the end
of 2023 and you're an extra three
percent body fat no but is it going to
be worth it if you achieve your goals
yes you need to decide in advance what
you're going to suck at
all right next one uh this was really
really good so I had this conversation
with James Smith about his new book uh
confidence which was brilliant uh and
you should go and check it out however
there was a quote that went up by Alex
homozy the day after we recorded it
which was so perfect and I it would have
been really great to discuss with James
so anyway I've got it here
you don't become Confident by shouting
affirmations in the mirror but by having
a stack of undeniable proof that you are
who you say you are outwork your
self-doubt which is just so bang on the
money and it summarizes my experience
with confidence over the last five years
I think
going from where I was as somebody that
uh was hopelessly unconfident with sort
of relatively low self-esteem in in
genuinely being himself and speaking
that forward
the only way that that could have
improved is by building a mountain in
layers of paint which is how Rogan says
it happens it's just a layer of paint
each single time every iteration every
single time that you face a challenge
and then you overcome it
um you need an undeniable stack of proof
especially if you're the sort of person
who is thinking about confidence right
if you've just if you're one of these
super outgoing people for whom
confidence just seems to arrive at you
relatively easily
this isn't a question for you like you
just lean into it and nail it however
outwork your self-doubt by having an
undeniable stack of proof that you are
who you say you are
almost allows you to lead from action as
opposed to lead from belief and those
two questions that I think that were
interesting uh when it came to
confidence so the first one being am I
trying to be more confident than my
competence level so
this the first one happens on your
journey uh earlier in your journey and
the second one happens a little bit
later so first challenge is relatively
simple to fix right all that you need to
do is create more successful iterations
of whatever it is that you're trying to
do so if you create that stack of
undeniable proof that you are who you
say you are
then
it's your job to or if you don't have
that right if you don't have a stack of
undeniable proof then you're not asking
for self-belief you're asking for
delusion like if you have little proof
that you can do a thing and are
complaining about the fact that you
can't believe in yourself doing the
thing what do you want you want fantasy
you don't want uh confidence confidence
without competence is a delusion
depending on your predisposition to
confidence however this can kind of lag
behind right so if you're someone that
is chronically underconfident uh it will
take longer for you to create that
undeniable stack of proof and you know
it could be two or five years or it
could be 500 podcast episodes it could
be whatever however in my experience the
seconds the confidence through
competence thing it usually takes about
two to three times longer than you think
it should to arrive especially if we're
talking about
the kind of people that I think we will
but that just requires staying patient
and continuing to iterate the Second
Challenge is the more
um nuanced one the more difficult one
and it's due to imposter adaptation
which again bro science alarm that's the
tendency of a lack of self-belief to
persist even as you continue to disprove
it with success in the real world so no
matter how many times you succeed no
matter how many times you were hugely
unsure if you were ever going to be
capable of succeeding and you do
you still don't seem to be able to
arrive at a place of genuine faith in
your own abilities your confidence is
yet to catch up to your competence so
remember that in the first one you are
asking for more confidence than you had
competence and in the second one you're
asking your confidence to then catch up
so the first one is delusion and the
second one is this imposter adaptation
taken from a hedonic adaptation and
imposter syndrome Blended together so
the truth I think that everybody that is
competent and yet still has that
beginner
um I am very fragile with my success
mindset needs to believe is that there's
only so many times that you can disprove
your imposter syndrome in the real world
and it still persists until you finally
admit to yourself that it's got nothing
to do about your capabilities and
everything to do with a mental Rhythm
and addiction to feeling like an
imposter if you've crushed every single
one of the challenges that's been put in
front of you and you're continuing to
grow and improve and you still don't
feel confident in yourself it's no
longer about competence it's all about
self-image so one of the best things
that I did was
when uh and a good event occurred when
there was a big challenge that I tried
to overcome and it ended up being
successful I took two to three minutes
afterward to really try and sink into
that feeling of what it feels like to
have completed a challenging task that I
was certain was going to wreck me and I
wasn't going to be able to do and come
out the other side and go right
[ __ ] I actually did that that was
amazing and this is from hardwiring
Happiness by Rick Hansen where he
mentions that you have a a the
opportunity to
create a rhythm to further engender the
type of uh brain patterns the myelin
sheaths that get laid down around the
myelin
um you can really lock those in more
effectively if you just take a little
bit of time to think about something
good after something good has happened
and it has to work with confidence as
well it absolutely has to because
if you a lot of the time if you if
you've overcome something that was
difficult immediately afterwards you're
always peering over the present moment's
shoulder in a desperate attempt to see
what you've got to do next it's like oh
God so glad that I got past that right
what's next it's like no no no no hang
on a second like [ __ ] allow yourself
to sit with that for at least a little
while and if you can just
consider how
well everything went and and really
assess whether or not the presumption
you had going into it matched with your
experience during it you were certain
that you weren't going to be able to do
it despite the fact that you've got this
stack of proof already that you could
have done it but the Imposter adaptation
meant that you didn't believe that you
could have done it and now you did okay
right now is the closest that your
competence is ever going to be to being
able to disprove your lack of
unconfidence right or your lack of
confidence
the closest that your competence is ever
going to be to saying you unconfidence
you should [ __ ] off because what you
said to me that I was going to be able
to do is miles away from what happened
in the real world and just allowing that
situation to just sit and you don't
really need to do much but
just breathing through it
you know a gentle review allowing the
feelings of emotion and satisfaction and
gratitude and competence to really
Infuse you that
seems to me to have made a pretty big
difference uh and it's cool it's in two
minutes five minutes or whatever after
something good happens take yourself off
to one side or that evening before you
go to bed
[ __ ] hell when I woke up this morning
I thought that everything was going to
turn [ __ ] and at the end of today I
really performed for myself I should be
thankful I should be grateful I should
feel whole I should feel competent I
should feel confident and that is how
you start to outwork yourself out right
it's not just the things that you do
it's the way that you see them being
done it's not just the achievements that
you have it's your ability to remember
and recall them and
yeah that's been a that's been a big
help another thing actually that I've
done is um
instantiate that gratitude and stuff
into celebrations so for instance
next week or right now actually today on
the day that this episode goes up uh I'm
gonna be in Las Vegas so I'm flying out
to Las Vegas and I've got some of my
best friends in the entire world flying
out Zach's coming out from Austin and
Skye the guy that does my ads video guy
Dean is flying out uh Ben my assistant
is coming over George Mack is flying
from Dubai Michaela Peterson is flying
from Miami Colton's coming from
Nashville so I've got this big group of
people there are many people that aren't
going there because they couldn't or we
couldn't get a villa that was big enough
uh but there's a big group of people and
that's going to be a way for me to round
out the end of the year and really think
about how well everything has gone I
wanted to it's a celebration it's like
um
a milestone that is very difficult for
your mind to ignore you know if you if
you do something that is purpose built
as like a
um a Shrine to the good [ __ ] that you've
got going on the good things that you've
done makes a really [ __ ] cool
solution and um yeah you know whether
it's hitting sales targets or kids going
off to school or or anniversaries with
Partners the reason that you do those
things is that it it Force feeds you
gratitude you have it's very difficult
for you to not feel that degree of
gratitude right
um another thing that you could do as
well is find a community of like-minded
individuals that are competent and
supportive and positive within whatever
domain it is and then speak to them
regularly
um one of the best things that's
happened again this year since being in
Austin is being around so many people
that are uh that I admire within the
world that I exist in that I can ask
questions of and can give me feedback on
my work and it's really important to
have people that you admire because it
means that the
insights and opinions that they give you
about your work or whatever goals it is
that you're trying to achieve are so
much more difficult to ignore like what
was it what was that quote earlier on
about people with low self-esteem are
always going to find a way to be
miserable it's like people with low
self-confidence are always going to find
a way to disprove whatever the world's
successes are giving them and um having
somebody that you admire tell you
something like you dude you really
[ __ ] crushed that or whatever you
know let's say that you really look up
to your parents about the way that they
raised you and starting to create a um
a conversation with them about the way
that you're raising your children might
be a really smart thing to do because if
you respect their child rearing
abilities and their positive and
supportive and so on and so forth and
they said you know what it is you're
doing a really really great job with
that kid you're gonna be like wow you
know someone that I thought was super
competent within this world is telling
me that I am as well so yeah
um all in all you need to iterate in the
first instance in order to be able to
accumulate that undeniable stack of
proof and then in the second instance
you need to allow your successes to seep
into you and drag that confidence back
up to the level of competence that
you're at as I said uh proof eats belief
for breakfast you don't need faith in
your abilities you have evidence outwork
yourself out
all right so I'll leave it there uh
thank you so much uh for tuning in thank
you for this year thank you for all of
the support thank you for the the
comments and the shares we were in the
top top oh we were the 99th percent we
were more shared on Spotify this year
than 99 of all of the podcasts which is
just like insane so thank you um if
you've enjoyed what I've spoken about
today that is available on a newsletter
that goes out every Monday and it's free
and there is a reading list that you can
get so if you go to chriswillx.com books
you can get my reading list for free
it's 100 of the best most interesting
and impactful books that I've ever read
summaries about why I like them and
links to go and buy them and that adds
you to my newsletter where all of this
stuff was seen first scattered
throughout this entire year
that's it
roll on 2023
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]